so Dominic McGregor welcome mother
wisdom Hawaii go to Frankie are you for
a drive for you yeah if you could drive
down from Newcastle to Manchester in the
Ray which is a typical British weather
so it's it's crazy to come into this
office which is several thousand square
feet and it looks like a labyrinth with
sleeping pods and a bar and a fully
functioning kitchen with a chef in and
all the rest of it and this is where
memes are made that run around the USA
writes the meme factory oh yeah I don't
I don't I didn't like that title it was
a gardenia and it just covers the mean
factory which we are you know we we make
a lot of of content here but yeah a
little bit about us so we started in the
room next door with like a white table
which like the same one that we're on
here there was thinking as it was far
enough on for every single person and we
were sat and I think these are very
similar to the white tables we had we
thought there was a little bit memory
and we working in the room to start in
social chain which is in a marketing
agency and it took us you know three or
four months to really find out that
we're actually on something and what was
different between us you know any other
marks agency is we don't big communities
so we owned big social media pages from
student problems Spa love food beef
motivation and we work with brands on
them communities so I'm right in saying
that you guys have got access to about
400 million people is that right yeah
yeah the total combined reach across the
place for 400 young people yeah yeah
cross the world which is we have
followers in like Taiwan looking to you
every like who's got 400 million of
anything it's just crazy when you find
into a graphic it's like ridiculous
that's terrifying both sort I found out
about you guys about two years ago from
one
best mates have actually worked for you
yep and what he explained to me about
social chain at the time felt absolutely
groundbreaking that you guys have access
to the network you understand the
platform yep and then you do the
creative yep and for me I was like how
has no one come up with this before
because influences have been around for
what like 5-10 years
yeah yeah oh really prevalent yeah yeah
I think I think the reason we we fell
upon it is that and we we had influence
I guess book our influences wasn't our
faces mm-hmm so we had to we had to
fight it what was the first page that
you started off with student problems
was it really yeah who started me you
start you know way so I was I was a
University in Edinburgh and I went out
one night but I honestly was like a
really heavy night was like awful faith
its [ __ ] think you are I think it's
exactly five years ago today no I think
I think I'll double check I think it was
the 7th of February that's fantastic so
I think is it went out and woke up the
next day and have no toilet paper in the
toilet so instead of you know unleash
him that the shop was down the bottom of
the street I could what about it so
instead of going getting it I decided to
start to a page and tweet about my life
who did nobody told up if I had no paper
yeah and then for the next couple of
weeks just tweeting everything that I
was doing listed up my life through my
eyes so like realizing how expensive
cheese was for example which is very
expensive imagery but will you move out
I love cheese and then just nothing like
that and then it got to like 20,000
followers in the space of two weeks and
then Steve Bryant touching me because he
was ruining the website which was like
commentary for students okay it was
called ballpark right and he was kind of
just doing a traditional not traditional
marketing methods by leaflets and
nightclubs and yeah everything else
before dates training with students and
took a step back of it and actually
realize that so that social is where
students has been in their attention
absolutely looked on Twitter for
students shared problems came up emailed
me we met in vodka reps in New York for
about an hour HR and
after that conversation I dropped out
University moved to Manchester start
looking at wall parking with him and
then we built more and more social media
pages to the point where we've got about
10 million driving traffic to wall park
realize that you know what one day we're
going to get money from appetizers we
could drive many people to wall park
we've got 10 million people on social
whywould advertisers want to be on the
website when they can just be on social
media nations or directing car the
middle exactly so we start putting
brands on social discovery that website
travelled the world found more people
who run big social pages like Hana who
run Hogwarts logic which is the big
Harry Potter page yeah got them all
together put them in the warehouse here
and and just we just tried to see if
this was something and it was it
definitely feels like it is isn't it
mm-hmm
it's great it's absolutely mad that you
guys are the forefront of a wave sort of
social media not in terms of adoption
but more in terms of how its how the use
from marketing is being delivered to
people yeah I think that that organic
genuinely creative adding value kind of
content yeah yeah I think I think it's
meaningful yes people people we as
generation and pretty sure everyone's
got ad blockers young they're up top
they're sick of telling being told what
to do by brands you know how our whole
thing is now how brands can actually
form a connection and care about their
consumers and we know as people
individuals ourselves what we purchase
now actually depends most wrong what the
brand says about what's rather than
anything rather than quality rather than
costs instruments and so self brand with
them exactly that's interesting coming
at it from a club promoters perspective
because everyone goes out to a club
event on the night and everyone
listening all know you get tagged in the
photos yeah and then the next day the
album goes up and they get tagged in
them and that tag stays in your facebook
profile with the watermark at the event
at the bottom yet and that means oh I'm
a I'm a voodoo girl like
I like this kind of music yeah and
immediately as soon as someone sees that
on your Facebook profile they can make a
whole bunch of assumptions about who you
are and about the values that you have
and they're not normally wrong no
they're not which is I guess the same
way you could probably do it free look
at someone's YouTube history which is I
always say that if you go on someone's
YouTube's just their videos yeah that is
how you find out who they are that's a
really really good point
honestly works just as well it's just a
together history isn't public is it
girls on this is the worst one honestly
go slot zero because a lot of them
murders and mass murderers and serial
killers really yeah because they're just
think really interested in my crime and
stuff my ex was like yeah
try and find out all they ought to be
detectives zero in for some reason
Fahrenheit and so you've got yourself
into social chain yep is that where do
you when did you begin the actual brand
or social chain when dude does yeah so
we are at wall park for about Steve
Steve Saturday when he was in eighteen
so he was doing it's about three years
out about a year and then when we saw
that back to the investors we have it
time out went traveling the world we
have who is this kind of talk of social
chain we came up the name pretty early
on when we sort of ballpark button it
didn't mean anything
yeah and we got this is like social
chain to chain of pages you know just
this this is what is our social change
what's driving people to walk back and
then we went to Thailand I went to
Brazil New York did it you know bit
living life iPhone no not bad no we were
doing market research 21 Tony we'd
actually spent some time in Silicon
Valley do you do some work yeah we did
do some work yeah and when to the World
Cup in Brazil which is called that's it
that was really good yeah and but I
thought it was gonna be full of girls
but it was the World Cup it was just
full of bugs everywhere
Argentinean that which is cool but yeah
well thanks for a while when 2020 2021
you got to resolve
Sam expecting like something different
yeah
then we came back from that because one
of our clients who we were doing
consultancy for wanted us to launch
their new product okay
so we've launched their new products and
they tend around the office investment
well yeah so did really well got to
about four million users they invested
and that's when social chant became a
thing okay which was third in November
2014
so that's not long ago at all no talking
about three now Fiorina not well yeah
three four yet show period that's crazy
and to get from there to now accessing
four hundred million people can you
think of a top three favorite campaigns
that you guys have done anything that
springs to mind of people might not yeah
we did one most people know is we did a
campaign when we hijacked a billboard in
Manchester and put welcome to that on
Wednesday and even have it signed for
Man United
yeah I was pretty well-known we've got
some really cool things in most of I
like that we've done is a little bit
more underground so we've done some
really cool campaigns you Skype that and
where we filmed 2 grands doing taking
part in super six which is pretty cool
it's kind of showing the use case of the
app and then I think you know that's the
crazy side of things we blew up a VW
Beetle super dry on Halloween right pray
for that on Facebook like yeah is that
one of the ones were prepared to do okay
I see it
I saw did you guys do the one was it
pretty little thing yep yeah which was
like it was that maybe a balloon yeah
yeah I've seen I saw the one for that
yeah we've learned a couple things up
and that's like one of the most highly
engaged live streams yet ever yeah 2.5
million views about a million comments
in probably a couple of hours yeah yeah
I mean as soon as I saw that go out I
then saw ones where ice creams were
melting in the Sun and people had to
comment on what
was gonna melt first yeah if that kind
of was the first foreigner
yeah and that sort of stuff go out live
so we were the first people to do
produce live streams yes so there's no
phone up in live stream like the drummer
put off yes yeah yeah yeah you know
German drum and central is just running
yeah that's funny I was the first ever
use of live stream on so Toph was it
really yeah well the first was
accidental it was like but it's really
good but like we were the first ones to
do a can orchestrate it yes planned
produced live streams which when we do
more things up and did some quizzes but
it's been that kind of like fast fashion
space super dry whoo-hoo pretty often
successful so everyone that's listening
on use social media to some extent and a
lot of people will use it by in one form
or another to either raise their profile
which is brings them some sort of equity
back or like myself it becomes kind of a
little bit more of a brand and is
directly associated with what your
company is doing yeah
are there any are there any principles
that you think that you found out that
people should be using on social media
because it's very easy to get caught up
in the air and this in a second it's
very easy to get caught and distracted
on social media cuz that's the purpose
of it yeah but in terms of trying to use
it effectively
I mean I'm gonna guess having a
producing content that adds value
whether it's a personally or yeah
actually I think I think and research
malaria to like personal branding
everyone's really got to understand way
of social fitness their life and it's
like a short window for who you are as a
person so you reader if you want to so
people don't want to do this but if you
want to like use it to your advantage
and really like showcase you as an
individual odd you know what you're
trying to achieve in your life and a
journey you've got to just think about
what you want it to
Tyumen to come across and I think some
people are on the other side of the
climb knows when I use it to if you
things up to the friend indigenous I
thought well yeah my mum does it she's
got one friend of facebooking to me is
it and she she like will message
backwards and forwards and send video
usage of it will be really heavy but
it's be incredibly narrow
my grands the same as you've got faith
likes 30 friends which is old family but
every time post anything I get like 10
likes because I've got my mom my dad my
grandma granddad my answer it's like all
right so you straight you're already
boost it looks like a really engaged
post yeah yeah got it yeah I think the
key is like really understand like
auditing yourself and why why you should
be using it it's difficult once we say
this we say it's from so I always feel
like saying it's from someone who like
knows the world like I will go into the
mob like what would be both being proved
a little bit older it's very difficult
for 17 16 year olds 3 understand to have
that perspective yeah you know I agree
so I think one of the things I want to
talk about today is the ethical use of
time on social media it's as far as I'm
concerned an emerging topic at the
moment yeah I wouldn't say that it's
been tremendously widespread yet but Sam
Harris and a guy called Tristan Harris
who is product philosopher at Google did
a really famous podcast about three
months ago he can find it on some
Harris's podcast waking up on iTunes if
you wanna have a listen yourself and
time well-spent calm is Tristan Harris's
website and on that what he discusses is
the cognitive biases that are being
leveraged by apps and by developers in
order to keep people's time on site and
they say that there's only so many hours
in a day and that YouTube is competing
with Facebook is competing with Netflix
is complete with everything to try and
maximize the time on site so I wanted to
ask yourself as someone who is driving
engaging content online which means that
people's time on site and time on screen
will be increased
do you have you got any concerns about
this yeah I think I've taken step back
also is we are very humans or animals so
we are very influenced by like social
and you can see on games like candy
crush the way they reward their kind of
though the mid-levels with their hits
and they're like you know all that is
designed towards keeping people
addicted and I the strong belief that
from two sides of the coin really as a
publisher
people always conceived content it's
always been the same we've had the same
issues with with TV to an extent not
more of the addiction side of things but
the kind of I guess you have got smaller
blessing with TV you know you've had
people who have very sedimentary because
they're always on watching TV but I
think with what is the important what
social it's stage people again a younger
generation these people a lot more
highly influenced and not as developed
they're not as assured of themselves let
alone that their surrounding so yes I do
feel kind of responsible in that
instance and I think more can be done to
educate young people but again it's very
difficult cause they're in a young girl
often it's interesting because you guys
have got you've got the access yeah
which is from knowing what the company
is about I definitely say that everybody
here as far as I'm aware and the company
culture is an altruistic one now if that
sense of genuinely caring about people's
well-being is to the contrary of what
advertisers want I guess therein may lie
a little bit more of a difficulty but
certainly for me it doesn't feel like
coming into the guys who make global
trends and social medias office it
doesn't feel like I'm stepping in this
underworld yeah like people trying to
desperately core young kids time and
make them feel incredibly self-conscious
online and like desperate for lights and
things like that
there's definitely an argument to be
made I think that you know student
problems was born of a genuine care or a
genuine interest in the topic could you
argue now that that's been monetized and
it's being used as a commercial vehicle
but the argument is that you're still
making content that's even better and is
still providing the same
same end result for you yeah completely
and I think we vacuumed his massive
responsibilities on the other side for
us to be able to educate people so we've
recently done a documentary on mental
health on student problems well we've
been gone to Bristol University where
last year there was 8 suicides an app
year like I had very high number of
suicides with some number one on the one
killer of men under 40
yeah it is absolutely terrifying topic
yep but yeah so and you go to university
to narrate the best free is your life
and you know a lot of people a lot of
you know students who wanted to get
suicide so we we have a responsibility
from that side of the fence
yes provide content which is
entertaining and relevant also to act as
the voice of a generation where we
educate them on life from the topics
that they really need to know about as
well so yeah we feel like we've started
to feel that responsibility a lot more
and I think the fact is that it's
emerging right you don't know it's like
when a new drug comes out onto the
market we don't with the side effects of
it until it's been in circulation in a
while yeah and the same thing with
social media that we only realized what
it was and we it's still emerging as
what actually social media is and how
all the different platforms work before
you then move on to tech addictions yeah
and then everyone's different there as
well ever has different relationship
with it absolutely so it's very
difficult to thank knows anyone so it's
like and I guess if you ask someone what
their relationship is then always going
to tell you is healthy they're not gonna
really like because of the thing is you
instrument so high that real you know
you run Instagram you call your friends
posting there might be no holidays to
get the feeling that you're sat there at
work not doing anything so that that yes
use social media but it has a bigger
impact in your life than just the actual
addition to the phone or that you know
that excite of things it has a longer
lasting effect so it's interesting
because especially with Instagram I read
this quote online which I thought was
really timely and it base
said that Instagram specifically you
compare the best of everyone else's life
with the worst of yours yeah because you
view your own life through a lens of you
completely understanding of all of your
things you see you see the blooper reel
and that's what sticks yeah because I
mines a Teflon for good thoughts and the
alcohol for bad thoughts that's how we
evolved yeah the person that the
Neanderthal the human that was living in
a cave that decided that they weren't
worried is the one that got eaten first
okay they were the least risk averse yep
the ones that are risk averse were the
ones so it means that we're hardwired to
think about things negatively and you're
right when you see the best of other
people's lives but the worst of yours
it does lead with a very very harsh
crunch and it's funny in this space I
think that influencers need to be more
accountable because they're create an
unrealistic expectation of life which is
more detrimental then as posting videos
of cheese on a page I agree
so I think that's that's where I think a
bigger issue lies with the
responsibility bad influences to to
really like know the other ones are
damaging it because they're they're
showing unrealistic well that's more if
you're an influencer it's a lot more of
a surreptitious delivery of the brand
message yeah because it it comes about
irrelevant of whether
which brand is tagged in your outfits or
what supplements at the front of your
training session or who it is that's
paid for the video production or the
photo to be taking it people don't see
that they see look at the condition of
this particular guy but the ass on this
particularly oh look at how a site in
the holidays or cheese on a boat again
on yep and they always all say and
through their experiences and they've
had hard times we're not like probably
having it mate I may be doing it just
this custom and probably have but
they're having working influences
they've got quite easy life they don't
know stress I just didn't know
straightness and they they painted an
unrealistic expectation to young people
so there's maybe there needs to be a
code of ethics that influences should be
thinking about using when the
it's tough online yeah I think I think
so I think it'd be interested to see the
difference between so wanted to follow
influences and someone who doesn't
follow any influences absolutely let
them search things like Emil out or a
holiday or like an outfit because if a
girl notice a lot more in the female
States because they are the ones that
not to sound sexist or anything but they
are marvered users of social media for
certain types of I mean it's just you're
you're exactly in the position to know
what the stats are yeah yeah yeah
exactly and to handbook
they were private users in them if you
compare the girl who dis employing
influencers versus someone who does for
influencers and you ask them their ten
favorite brands you probably get a very
different answer I agree and then
probably satisfaction and like you say
you're going out for a meal yep and if
you've previously in the days seeing
that someone was it blue marlin Dubai
yet one of your favorite influences of
blue marlin - by having teriyaki salmon
and black cod and surrounded by million
pound yachts and then you've gone out on
Valentine's Day to somewhere that
doesn't fulfill that expectation you're
right it's it's not not tremendously
positive environment at times is it yep
and these are people you never you'll
never meet and that's that what they're
making you feel through in your
relationship it's ruining friendships is
ruining everything it's making such so I
think anyone so if you've got
affiliations with influences and stuff
like that would you be I'm gonna guess
the answers yes to this but you'd be
maybe pushing them to think about might
be a little bit more mindful with the
content and trying and difficult because
that's their livelihood as well say
you've got you've got a great balance
and I think I think it needs to be
something that comes iconically from the
influence of space they need to realize
some of them need to realize what
they're doing would be nice wouldn't it
maybe that maybe maybe that happened
over the years maybe so moving on to
another topic that both of us are really
passionate about
I want to talk about your problem with
substances that you've had over the
years
could you give us a bit of background on
that yeah it's always a fun story to
remember yeah I guess I guess my life
started like so that anyone else's you
know you go to university spend three
nights a week drunk is life then it was
a good night out my so I think why not
why not why not I used to finish
football training at telling go straight
to I not know RJ glass and the max wins
yeah yeah they're still they're still
doing it he's still killing it like it
why not if anyone's going to wedding
Brooke
why not Michael what eight years in a
row I think it's one like that yeah
Monday nights
that's the one it's got him there are
suddenly it's complete redesign yeah
let's go in led the room to is LEDs LED
walls it's fantastic anyway so yeah I
live a normal life and I would describe
myself the reason I think it's you know
problems was successful it's because I
was just sheet average student I was
completely straight in the other line
you know I'm not got a privileged
background I'm not I'm not from I've got
very middle middle of the road you know
representative yeah everything's about
can relate to everyone so that's why I
was a successful because it was it was
just what you'd expect the student to be
like and came to social status chain and
and you know what we we had a very a lot
of success very early and you are what
age Ramona I'm 21 21 this point C 21 and
a lot of success and a lot of spoken
Lincoln and really no responsibility to
anyone other than yourself and a lot of
spare time a lot of selves bedtime but
you know units and that's art so you've
got a concoction now of four elements
which fuel really a lot of partying
because you 21 the hedonic lifestyle
right you get the means and the ends to
do what you want exactly and so it
starts out like that it stop celebrating
you know that we've got some big client
wins we have a lot of success early on
so we all go as a team we've spent a lot
of time together having meals it is a
genuine eight at first it's celebrating
its this is fantastic and you know first
flash 14 years a year into the business
when you started
rocky patches you can't let other people
know that there's a issue of cash flow
and that you know you looking tight for
the wages next month you can't have that
on you've got a straight face in here
and you know business as usual and but
behind that kind of good face I'm
struggling really struggling and so with
22 number 22 yeah yep and the
celebrations continue because there's
still success but every single time of
these celebrations and partying I'm
drinking to excess and doing drugs
because you know we both spent on the
cash flow Cassius this miss Donnell and
but I'm doing it to Muscat feel I'm
doing it to escape I'm getting away from
the stresses the anxieties of what real
your pictures and it's almost this
oxymoron of where I celebrating everyone
all the stuff all the team was
celebrating because we've just done
something spectacular but I know deep
down that things are not rosy and yay
happy and on the outside on the outside
and they kind of allow any the
substances to carry that through and
play the role exactly exactly you know
be that person that continues for a bit
I mean how were you able to function at
work because it's not bad at this point
but it's it's no different than what the
everyone else would be doing it's just
the nice how it's the same it's the same
it's but I'm starting to feel like I'm
becoming the lion on that lifestyle and
that's what when I start to feel
something no just my whole life would
start turn into that kind of thing and
I've got God girlfriend he was really
bad for me really bad for me she created
this picture that social change was
wrong and you know mean her we're going
to live a free life and that it was just
a horrible relationship
and stresses at work at all not stresses
but the situation that it's a lot of
tighter and more responsibility more
people join their numbers we start
talking a bigger you know we're talking
million pound contracts was talking you
know couple legal battles come our way
as well which is which is you know all
adds up to it and then you know I think
I how am i Tony for yeah so there's a
kind of a three-month period when I
break with this girl because I get rid
of her and then the next three months is
worth Cheerios for me I I start drinking
on weekdays that's when and why I always
dreamt mine some red wine so I've come
across a wine you know became a reward
for a hard day I've got a white and it
got to a point where minute alcohol
passed my lips it would be above maybe
to Hobbs it would stop yeah
and that were gonna wait day and I get
okay and a couple of things happened
that really hit me hard
so it was Thursday night we went to
neighborhood open in here it's good
night yeah and I got absolutely off my
head and it's the first day and I go
home and I fall down the hill and my
house and Britt Malka it's a Wednesday
weren't Lisa Friday more than any
possible sites out there in a knee she's
going on at work I'm like what the hell
doing this yeah what [ __ ] I don't the
spot and that's what that was like
straight one stroke and then like
straight to well that was my birthday
right
7:23 a birthday I go out everyone it's
great it's gonna be a heavy one heavy
one obviously but the death words which
is natural Bertie has been they out I
spent like my 25th birthday
locked in a dark room watching a movie
ain't life hating life everyone wait
like let's go for a mirror to birthday
come on let's go
I'm just know that my stay here I spent
the whole day in a dark room my birthday
yeah and I'm thinking about everything
we've got my life and that's when I gave
up substances that I can k strokes it
has to be drunk now I can't I can't be
like this on weekend this is ruining my
PC room so I think you know I'll be fine
so I do I do six weeks about any
and he drugs and then I was still
drinking still drinking yeah yeah yeah
go to the races and I have a Great Dane
honestly every day I'm loving more happy
and but I come back home like 6 p.m. you
know off my head I've been invited there
by a friend in a sponsors box I've got
no alcohol all this all day and it's
nice day and I've still got a problem
where about a touch alcohol
I wouldn't stop drinking I have one in
my hand and I my behavior up day was I
got thrown out of pickle a nose you know
edge first stealing the bottle of wine
from someone's table and shouting abuse
of people well it was a different person
yeah and I said some mean things to some
perhaps bad things to a good friend of
mine yeah and it was the first time I've
ever hurt somebody else
yeah in a minute I hurt somebody else
and you I need to stop because I'm lost
not me yeah I could deal with her in
herself I was beating myself up not I
enjoyed that a little bit because it was
punishing myself at catharsis
yeah but I couldn't deal with that
hurting somebody else I would only got
run over by a car once yeah a couple of
things they really region when I was
drunk but I could deal with it was
making you it was me
but the minute it moved into me doing
damage to someone I cared about
and you had to stop and then I woke up
that day had a very very frank
conversation with Steve who wasn't there
daybook heard about it and I said that
I'm going to stop I'm not gonna drink
again never gonna drink again so how
long so bro you know 20 months 20 months
20 months yeah
from that day from that day never gone
back call turkey call turkey and what
was it like the first couple of weeks
it's tough it's change your life it's
not it's not true the alcohol the first
I always have this funny the first
weekend I woke up however I think the
body a body would say nice recover is so
it was is the problem of energy drinking
your body gets used to the shock in his
system every five days you know
a functioning organism is used to
repetitiveness yeah I work what I woke
up however because my body was it goes
dehydrated because it was probably
producing more things in the liver
pancreas to break down the art fault
and it wasn't that it wasn't that you
alright Don what's going on I need some
white yeah that was weird to the first
weekend I felt hung over so you don't
anything the benefits it wasn't so this
is my problem I try to try genuine you
don't feel benefit since like week six
so he's tried on Ruiz greatly the real
benefits that comes afterwards cheeky
enough to it
exactly and they felt difficult because
I had to change my entire lifestyle it
wasn't the alcohol it's my lifestyle I
had to remove myself we've taken far
beyond social drinking here haven't you
this is habitual needing drink yeah
Jordan beats and makes a really
interesting call about people that have
got substance abuse addiction and he
says that the addiction isn't a problem
a serious problem but until you need to
take the substance to deal with the
withdrawals from illness yeah and but
none of your tape until you're drinking
to cure a hangover because you're always
hungover
yeah you kind of in a different realm
and as soon as you cross that line
nothing and that's what and my weekend
was cuz I someone broke it down to me
Friday like what he used to get them
ready either used to feel it and ready
for it to be this is it honestly you
should feel like it was going seven-day
cycle hey guys getting ready for alcohol
to be in it so I'd get this like natural
high come Friday life free o'clock right
get energy and knows that it's going
awesome yeah yeah and I was going for
you coming for it yeah so free o'clock
I'm like yeah come on you know Fiona yes
it's kind of like because my mind News
I'm away from and then there we come
away from this dress I think I'd have to
reply to emails awesome April days
yeah so I'm putting it excited so that's
Friday yeah that's Friday like 3 o'clock
so you might have a few Minds already
somewhere else you got you got a Friday
Saturday run off kinda during today yeah
Saturday
so if some day recovering from some
recovering from Saturday at a diner
Friday and then you know what I was
seeing this girl you know we invented
tequila sundaes fantastic fantastic so
we had a couple of tequila Sundays so
you cannot fix the hangar
and is taper it off a little bit exactly
so we had a couple of drinks in the
night together
yeah and that then it's Monday you
Monday you're recovering when they stuff
so you go have a glass of wine at the
end of the day because I got through a
date on over exactly and then you know
maybe not choose it Wednesday because
she your love it especially and then
well why don't you mind your back up for
the weekend exactly it's interesting
it's really interesting I think there'll
be very enlightening for people to hear
someone who is from the outside looking
in definitely made of the dominance
hierarchy has got an awful lot going for
them but has struggled with something
that most people elect to do and find
and find enjoyable and I think one of
the key one of the key problems when
you're talking about sobriety or when
you're talking about trying to control
alcohol is that every drink that you
have makes the subsequent drink more
difficult to not have yeah yeah it's
like a feedback loop yeah you have one
and you're in a mission below and then
you have another and your inhibitions
lower and then before before long like
oh well like what's what's getting a
bottle of wine and if it's you know you
honored now what's again about you drugs
it what's getting this what's getting
that and you know I mean and then who
says no to the after party at your house
who says no to telling you friends
something the Turk for doing whatever
the inhibitions just continue to get and
then I'm down and then you also go into
the bad food yeah and that's a whole
number calif ish yeah because you just
then you see look at what you put you
know and when the guy said it here is
your brain cells are made up every
single thing that you put into your
mouth yeah yeah that's rain so you've
heard that yeah that's really true
that's gonna change your mind or things
but I'm like okay everything that goes
with my mouth makes my brain okay you
know cause my brain buildup
I probably overdose in Turkey
yeah that's what sort of what sort of
life is that going to be I think it's
really interesting might it's very very
insightful to hear from someone can you
hear these stories of like child
prodigies and you know Macaulay Culkin
asked characters that
too much too soon yeah but it's very
interesting to hear it firsthand from
somebody who definitely did have that
yeah and I think that alcoholism is
usually perceived by people to be or a
problem with alcohol is usually
perceived by people to be mid-50s guy
with the bottle of scotch whiskey ever
laid on his couch sipping it from that
is one employee these are benefits is
this than the other but it's not a
problem with alcohol is that you cannot
deal with what alcohol does to you in
your body yep if you have I've got a
number of friends that range from
introvert to extrovert from depressive
to happy and the guys that are depressed
or that have a depressive personality
they need to restrict the drinking
100% is that you saying that they need
to it's me you don't need that they're
speaking from personal experience I do
not deal well with hangovers and then if
you throw into that mask if it mix if
one of your personality traits is being
industrious and you've got high goals
and you have high standards for yourself
they say the ultimate pain is when the
person you are makes the person you
could have been yeah and that that's the
difference in pain of what you feel yep
like if you set your goals very very
high and then you start to bring
yourself down in your performance others
performance at work performance in
relationships or moments with everything
if you do that to you so you're electing
to make yourself slow yeah and one of
the mad things I always use this example
especially about people that use like
that you've really really heavy drugs so
if you talk about pills or MDMA that
kind of wash a sequence or a night's
experience with the same flavor so you
hear guys that go out and go on the stag
do they go Vegas you travel halfway
around the world to go to Vegas and they
get absolutely blitzed out of their mind
can't remember half the night and then
they'll take a drug that is so immersive
that they literally could have gone down
the road to the bill and have the same
experience yeah the only difference that
you choose when you go away on a holiday
and you decide to fill yourself full of
alcohol and drugs is what environment I
want to have my come down and hang over
it yeah that's the only thing that you
change completely
I play and you know what I the perfect
come down and
I the dark room which is like cinema
room a dark room full of snide blackout
blinds
block out everything honestly pitch
black so you know that's the dream yeah
I used to I used to remember planning my
Sundays yeah other dominoes this the
weekend our honor roll around and come
down this is there this is the treat for
myself and mentally rewarding yourself
of a comedown what how I ever gonna get
you to where you want to be you're
completely right and the point that when
you get to when you get to the pain of
staying the same
you know you something like this isn't
me this isn't who I want to be I don't
want to be a person in five years the
person I want to be in five years is
doing it did dirt I need to do something
to make a change yeah I mean there's
absolutely some people who don't have a
problem with substances I have a I'm a
club promoter right that's why I did for
a living
like we see this we see every single
person strata can you see the people who
are suffering are John and I are not and
I don't know because everyone on a night
out again you've got alcohol bring the
guys that are on a night out even the
ones that have got depressive
personality are the ones they're
suffering it needs to be chronic like
read a fear for someone to be in the
middle of a night out ten beers deep and
still not happy because again the
alcohol in the drugs they wash the
environment with the rose-tinted colored
glasses and then everyone's having a
good time and that the life and soul of
the party but a lot of time it's the
people if you want to try and identify
the people that are struggling the most
with the substances look at the ones
that the most now coming on and I yeah
yeah Nick Joe my mind got bad my
scientist drink alone yeah that was the
winner that's what I knew I'm sat there
i call the nice right just like I
remember he remember drinking come upon
the wine I heard later on Saturday I
wasn't going out I don't know why yeah
and I left at 45 minutes away and I text
a friend to ask me bring some coke yep
the house an hour away on our way on
your own oh my god so you can just rack
up line since the other way can you
imagine that
and that's it you know there is a lot of
side that there's absolutely people for
whom substances aren't a problem I have
a wide range of friends who party to
different differing degrees yeah people
he would go out and a sober because they
choose two people who go out sort of
consciously to know it's bad for them
people who drink and pick apart your
excess and within each of those
categories you have people who are able
to recover from it and for whom it is
absolutely fine yeah but you know if
you're one of those people you know if
you're not you absolutely know for me if
you are waking up the next day you might
not know it's because of the alcohol but
if you're waking up the next day and you
feel worse than a hangover should make
you feel and you know what the cut I
think you you know how I hope it should
be but if you start becoming
self-referential yeah and if you can't
get out of bed for the day and if you
start thinking that I'm not actual izing
my potential all the things that you've
identified that's you know that that's a
highlight yeah so talk to me about what
sobriety stuff what I've lost
rat free enough stone we see a picture
you see a picture
I gotta help it up on the screen hold on
the screen but this is this is all
three-and-a-half stones so that's like
what like 18 kilos 15 kilos something
like that 21 21 kilos yeah I was yeah
that's that's me me oh well that photo
looks like it's been stretched yeah I
thought it looks like it's been
stretched in widescreen but it's not you
just massive just muscle so this wasn't
me you're completely spherical I know
all right
but isn't it which is crazy absolutely
crazy and that one that oh wow yeah
that's um that's a different guy than
the one that I'm looking at at the
moment yeah
it's a different shape face you know
some clear as well yeah for sure
so you take on sobriety and
I get to either changes at that time I
acquired myself a loss but a lot more
time no you're not spending a game not
spending smashing okay so yeah it's to
interject at that point on the time
thing even if anyone that's listening
even if you think that maybe you don't
have a problem in terms of being self
referential with your own opinions on
your own sources yes if you look at your
year time - only thing we can't get back
right yeah if you look at your year as a
set of year and accounts for company
yeah and you want it to maximize
profitability which would be available
time to do with what you value
yep what you would do is you would look
at the biggest costs that you could get
rid of on that time and if you look
through that and every single week you
go your accountant looks at you says
what's what's between 7:00 a.m. and 4:00
p.m. every Saturday you do [ __ ] all and
then on a Sunday you're working a lot of
50% capacity and then in one day is
still only 8 percent capacity what the
[ __ ] you doing and you think right ok
even if I don't have a problem with it
just from a pure time efficiency
perspective if I want to maximize my
experience of life in the mirror 80
years that we've got on this planet I
need to make sure that I'm not
spasticated myself on a weekly pieces is
the problem that things it's the routine
is if you do it every week that's when
it starts to become like question last
thing I think someone should question
themselves because there's so many so
much more things to do out there you
know we do what we do live busy lives
you know we do work hard everyone does
work hard and so having that sense of
doing something you want to do yes and
it's new despite what people think it's
not going in that mess up with our
friends all the time there's all the
things they will find that they enjoy
absolutely so I found I love running I
love working out you'd have known that
the guy in those photos loved running
honestly genuinely doesn't look like he
could have ran a Burger King away I
would have run too baby I wear no runs
very big
your flights into the dealers examine
every their daring face eleganza yeah so
fun out of work I loved running I got it
and I guess I replaced one addiction
with a number but I loved how really
magic made me felt that were in the time
yeah it's true
runner's high is so true because there's
an element you run away from problems as
well a little bit but defeating them as
well with every step exactly so you've
got live polished tips as well so I fell
in love with that I fell in love with
the outdoors just in general being
outdoors being being around em and then
you know other things like writing right
now I've got a blog and posh tag yeah I
just talked about my day and then the
running there inside of things take me
all over the world I wanted to go see
some places with it so I'm going to
Lisbon next weekend to tell me how many
marathons have you got planned I've got
I'm doing 12 runs one-on-one a month
build a lot different sizes like 5k 10k
yes I'm doing a half marfan neck smoking
next week in Lisbon okay I'm doing
running Aloha in Scotland I'm gonna go
up to Edinburgh gonna be called so
everybody called you and then I bring
along the marfin in April nice and then
I'm very nine-month no way where's the
Omo Barcelona
that's sick it was just for why the
worst place yeah for sure this is a
couple better swim in a bike ride didn't
run that's amazing I mean you know
lastly there will definitely be people
listening to this who think that's not
me like I don't have a problem with with
substances I like to go out with my
friends and that for me is what I want
to do in my weekends and that's sweet
but I said during a podcast I did with
the CrossFit guys that I think they're
on about 25 it's like a fitness
menopause yeah cuz yeah you stop being
concerned if you've been like a gym bro
for a while you stop being concerned
with leading us at all costs and you
start to realize you're chronically
aware of your own mortality as you as
you approach the yeah and you think I
need to be from
I have to be able to put my put my socks
on and get up the stairs without getting
out of breath so you start to think
about more functional stuff with that
and I think that the same you can go
through a party menopause as well and
it's delivered at varying ages you know
you've you've maybe had an early
indoctrination yeah you went straight to
pro you went straight to pro level yeah
kind of yeah I went from student to
professional yeah yeah professional
mixed out everything came between idea
no there was no Club games no that's
straight to welcome yeah and you know I
think that as well people realize and
like for some people it's like being in
a relationship right like that kind of
opens people's eyes because the
girlfriend does one you going out and
get me act all the time you and the
boyfriend feels uncomfortable about you
being in clubs with the guys or just
generally you want to spend time
together because you've got someone
around yeah but even without that I
think that it is really important for
people to realize that there's more to
life than going out and getting
leathered and yeah you know I'm saying
this from under guy that makes a living
yeah mother one could meet 100 people in
the clubs every weekend what can I say
it's you know my business partner of 10
years had a chat with him you'd the day
he was talking about he's gonna go and
see one of his friends who was in rehab
it was 44 now and he was thinking to
himself at the time like what is it that
we're doing to people when we get them
to go out on a night out like what you
you hit the nail on the head that the
problem is going out and getting blitzed
every weekend yeah some people can go
out and they can have I've got a number
of friends that can do it that are in
the division 2 Division three parties
and they're able to go out they can do a
five-point night they can wake up the
next morning and maybe they shouldn't
drive but after they've had a bacon
sandwich
there's way to go yeah but you know I
mean yeah that's fine yeah things about
everyone really needs to ask themselves
their relationship with alcohol what do
they think it's helped me it's a hard
question to ask yourself because you
don't never want to sell analyze
negatively and I do think that there is
a subculture this is this is not this is
thinking is that there is a vegan trend
that's come up with the last couple
years is being started really grassroots
it really is from run by leaf people
yeah run by the you theory I guess
passionate about and a protection but
honestly what being a vegan dispute you
know there's a lot to be here oh yeah I
mean I may end up being a vegan
no no that's Sharon no neither I've
tried I'm aware that I definitely don't
need anywhere near enough vegetables so
I need I need to push that one of my
friends for an interesting Facebook
States up the other day talking about
it's trendy to be vegan at the moment it
is really trendy but the same people
that are giving someone grief or any
Canada Goose jacket will also be the
same one that will spend a hundred quid
on two bags of coke that's been done off
the back of dead children in Colombia
yeah you know gang wars and all the rest
of the stuff that get your get those
drugs up your nose yeah I just is
damaging and to a lot more sentient
beings than the coyote that's died to
make a jacket or whatever it might be so
but again without what people doing that
being very selective about what they
want to be self referential though
exactly and also works with social media
for how they seem absolutely the self
branding if that's fine yeah you're
never gonna put the video of you snort
in a line but you can definitely put a
video of you saying that it's bad - yep
share a video of someone trapping a
coyote for a jacket yeah I I think I
think I think the tea towel so movement
will come soon I think they'll be a rise
in young people which you've always
seemed to see that universities actually
a decrease in about time students go out
mainly because of money but I think
there'll be a little bit more education
on the space that you'll have
generations of young people who choose
not to generate I mean my Master's
dissertation was the effectiveness of
Antioch aha advertising on students at
Newcastle yeah and it basically found
that none of it was the people were the
crazy stories as a badge of honor they
literally say like how was your night
out man he was crazy and woke up in
hospital yeah huh like you think reframe
the conversation that you're having that
they did the same thing with smoking
when smoke
my own place yeah they they try for
years and years and years to get people
to smoke less said how I was going to do
- you think material in DC hat
it wasn't until smoking was banned in
clubs and you had to go outside smoke
that became uncle and smoking stopped
yeah
because suddenly this is Barrett's entry
but go outside and leave the pipe so
people stop smoking yeah it's
interesting I think it what specifically
interesting about this conversation is
that we've got two people coming a
sobriety from opposite ends and spectrum
so for the people that don't know I did
six months sober last year which began
December 2016 and finished in May 2017
and then I did six months of partying
again and drinking but after my six
months of sobriety which I only did to
see if I could do it I knew that I based
on the time availability set accounts
that I came up with and knew that if I
waited to be really successful for a
period and I had some plans things that
I wanted to achieve I needed to get some
more time up I need to squeeze more time
out of my day and that sobriety enabled
me to do that but we're coming at it
from someone who has used sobriety to
stop an addiction or to stop a habitual
problem with substances and then someone
who's coming from it who I wouldn't have
classed myself as having a problem with
alcohol and I've only drank can maybe
once every two weeks but the times that
I did it wasn't good for me yep
so I guess you've got a fairly wide
spectrum of people there that covered
yeah for whom sobriety so you were
talking really interesting where you
touched on about the six week point so I
didn't track it at the time I should
have written a diary and I did about
what the sobriety was doing to me
because I think I guess a lot of what
sobriety fee you would have meant would
have been not doing negative things
before they start to do positive things
yeah
whereas for me I was kind of starting I
guess from a baseline of okay day to day
and then improving from there yeah but
I've always said to my friends that to
talk to me about it
after about two months my mental agility
and my verbal dexterity just went
through his ruse ridiculous yeah and on
that point is think people everyone less
nothing is think deeply about when was
the last time you can pitch yourself go
alcohol from being 16 years old I use
this story all the time
you can't I couldn't I couldn't you know
you do address if you do address if you
do a dry run your rank yeah yeah
hungover so you have our fire system to
the second or third and then you know
what you'll give in the last weekend
because it's still January so you only
do like free fall away to Humble
everyone that's just completed try
genuine dry generators dry three weeks
if the dry four weeks you know bit of a
refresh my get back into the gym it's
not long enough to really know it's a
difference I drink I think six months is
a really intimidating amount of time but
for me the changes that it made for me
were absolutely fantastic like verbal
dexterity mental agility quality of
sleep ability to regulate emotions yeah
energy absolutely yeah and what it does
is I think it it starts to let you deal
with some of the things that more more
chronic birth being around for a little
bit longer the problems that require a
deeper look at yourself things to do
with your values and whether you living
with virtue and what what values you
want to be cultivating in the long-term
as a person because it's very difficult
to think about oh no I'm gonna live in a
virtuous life that is actuated my
potential when you're hanging out of
your ass filling your mouth full of
d'arnot's like Saturday or you waking up
with some girl whose name you don't know
it's competent compatriot because the
questions you ask yourself in them
situations are very small you don't ask
yourself big questions you know you're
when you're in a state of on over your
body is telling you honey food they
drink
I need sort of showing short-term
gratification urges this is what I need
to get over in the corner situation and
then let you say when you've got a bit
of head space and a bit of mental
bandwidth to ask yourself these
difficult questions I
never ever fall of what my values what
what if I use someone how we actually
did see a therapist strip it to track
over it and why things request accepted
me as you sir I don't values and all
your actions need to be in line with
your values of who you want to be as a
person as I've got the hello my values
I'm going about clean it's all being
washed under the rug man and you're
right like if you're if you're from
sixteen and spending time recreationally
for you is going up and getting blitzed
with you mates which you don't actually
know what life is outside of them no and
then all that you need to do is add in a
little bit of vicariously living your
life through other people through social
media through TV and all the rest of
this stuff and before you know it like
you beat yourself up over over where you
are yeah you you're causing the problem
or you're you're creating you're
building the wall that is so high you
can't climb over anymore
and you want to see the other side yeah
and I think that that that level of sort
of helplessness or just decisive action
yeah it's just decisive action and I
think that it's it's something that
people don't have to deal with and I
think that's that that's the key
takeaway from this is that you don't
have to go out and get absolutely blitz
because again like we say this differing
leaves apart yeah right yeah there's
there's the ones who've gone to the
absolute extreme and there's the ones
that have that are able to manage their
alcohol use and for the ones that do
then you know cracking on sobriety will
help and it will be a really really good
test for you in terms of can you win
something can you win a battle that most
people couldn't dust that's the big
thing there it's like proven to you so
that you can do so you know that 99
percent the rest of operation can't and
I think that is is it's a big thing
because a sense of achievement it's not
like he's like a it's real to badge of
honor
yeah I'm yeah yeah not that I work with
hospital but I'm sober yeah and and it
is an interesting thing I met a guy who
I've known for years from New York who's
probably like probably the footlong like
the face like best body guy and often
Chris
I know you body builds and I met em when
I must be like month friends have been
sober and he was like okay I could never
do what you do I was like for a minute
like so disciplined with his fitness
this guy's so disciplined in his life he
looks like a god he lives and you could
never do ideas over that was like I'm
one minute I'm doing something here that
is so far away from norm but I'm just
like I'm gonna discover new things
people are people that do it's really
rare for people to take notice of much
of what you post online if it isn't
something that's really monumental about
your family yeah like if it's not I'm
having a kid I'm getting married I'm
moving away like for the most part
unless it's something really funny that
the bags yeah like it's like a 300 like
hear about someone that's parked on the
street even follow my way except me okay
yeah unless it's one of those ones like
you don't and you don't people don't
come up and speechy both I only cost
about maybe three or four times last
year the number of people that came out
to be right and said may you see still
do not six months other thing yeah four
key now like what's going on
yeah like but it's it's not that big of
a deal minivan out how are you do you
know it's just like it's just one of
them things like you've got you know how
do you not like and after a while when
people search our drink and you can know
and you can say to you this without
being twenty I'm doing six months sober
arm and doing a period of sobriety so
and on that point as well the biggest
reason why people say they could not do
it is because they don't mean it could
have fun what I and your you are there
in a situation where you still out with
people your friends you going out to eat
in then I out you're out later probably
than any ever stop and you're having
more fun yeah and that's like the
biggest the biggest thing I hear from
people is I can never do it to feel like
I'm a boring I don't my friends I'll
think of me so here we go
people use alcohol 100 percent on an eye
out to mask the fact that they're not as
extroverted as their friends the
that they are yeah then that they're
worried that they're not as good so that
is the equivalent of taking a
performance-enhancing drug to be able to
perform at an adequate level in your
sport of choice
yeah so if you are on a night out and
you don't you've got approach anxiety as
bigger pies so we call it they're going
up and speaking to a girl I'd remember
when I was in uni I'd be like I like
can't go talk to that girl knocked back
five Jager bombs and then you wake up
within the next morning yeah because he
like oh I don't know why I said right so
it got rid of the inhibitions got lower
than the approach anxiety went away
and the same thing goes for being with
your friends like there's this funny
quote that I know from one line that
says nothing good ever happens after
2:00 in the morning and you're like the
last hour of a club night unless you're
in somewhere like that a late night
venue during a typical Club that's ten
to 3:00 or 11:00 till 3:00 the final and
I watch it like I sit and I look like if
you want a bit of advice leave the club
at 2:00 in the morning like leave the
club at 2:30 in the morning because
nothing good happens in the final half
an hour or the final hour
it's people strongly now it's issues at
the bar it's people getting in scraps
it's this than the other like you can
have the lion's share of the night with
non of the regret the next morning and
none of the problems the next morning
and on top of that you can remember it
yep and you know if you drive it's
cheaper yeah because you drive they grab
your friends drop-off you're going you
want to and you know I've been out I
caught as much now as I did then another
bet time and I'm sure I completely agree
the point - because the moment right
when you were your friends okay and it's
it's it's not about 1:30 2:00 o'clock
where things deteriorate for that they
go from having normal conversation to
just being a mess and it's you sit there
and you're completely fine it's like
they're calling them so is the next
point and we did this discussion once I
completed the six months sober with a
guy called James Bailey who is from
Basel and he brought up this really
really interesting point
do you thoughts on here he said that
curing an addiction doesn't involve to
on cold turkey it involves the
reintroduction of the substance on your
terms hmm so can you ever see yourself
in the either short medium or long term
reintroducing or attempting to
reintroduce alcohol if you can tell me
one reason reason why if anyone can have
a wrong reason why I just have in my
body okay so because alcohol and other
substances yeah as much of a part of the
experience of life as anything else is
yeah now you could say as I do to people
when they ask about why I'm are not
drinking as much my main reason is I've
served my time yeah like the same way
you do you have you military service
yeah I'm like I've served my time pi and
I did a decade of partying yeah and
right now I don't need to but you could
argue that by not reintroducing alcohol
or by not using alcohol that again
you're now living in limit and limited
limited yeah life on one side cuz don't
get it wrong like I've had some [ __ ]
wicked night I played out of my tree
like I have had some really really fun
times yeah and that's not to I
absolutely would not have been able to
achieve those nights out sober yeah
there's an element of the night that we
can sing the praises a sobriety all we
want but there's some nights out that
just get going because everyone's
blitzed yeah completely and I think
definitely definitely not for the very
foreseeable future I don't think I don't
think it aligns us with with me and my
values are all the same and this ago
somebody stupid the same way same way
some people vegetarian this soon doesn't
something I I don't I honestly feel that
I don't need it I think I have fun I
guess on the second part and maybe I'm
not over the addiction interesting I
think
I think that this definitely it shows
the fact that you're able to make that
admission show us how much time you've
spent being self reflective yeah because
a lot of people wouldn't have even been
able to identify the addiction in the
first place or the other habit was a
problem yeah that a lot of 20 months
down the line to be able to say I've
still got more of this journey to go
before I can actually consider going
back in your direction yeah my I I lived
my life we ran away from that moment
where I knew I had to stop like I live
did not never thought I ever again so
there's a an interesting thing I'm doing
Jordan Peterson day at the moment
there's an experiment was done with rats
but rats of who achoo yeah and they
hadn't been fed for a while they touched
a spring around the tail and they put
cheese at the end and they washed it the
smell of cheese in so they could smell
the food and the rats pulled a
particular force when this spring then
what they did was they wafted the smell
that cut in from behind them I need a
thought the rats are starving they're
gonna pull as hard as they can already
but they didn't be my fourth thing so it
increased and what he says is that in
life you don't just need to run towards
something that you want you need to run
away from something that you fear yeah
that's why I mean so much don't man I've
really I've really really enjoyed this I
would love to do it again I'm gonna put
the links to Tito Runner and everything
else yeah
social chain guys if you want to check
out Hogwarts logic or just look on your
Facebook feed or your Instagram feed
there's probably gonna be something from
you guys the heads up on that I really
appreciate your time yeah thanks Cheers
thanks Polly
[Music]